hans what a game today take us through
some of the key moments you chose this
very wild
extremely modern type of chess opening
tell us what your thought process was
choosing it well it's not really my
choice yeah it's his choice to play
bishop c5 instead of bishop before
uh so
yeah okay of course uh for the audience
yeah here like uh bishop bishop before
is the
it's more um his
tendency so the things he had no games
here so i wasn't sure which one he would
go for right and uh i spent a little bit
more time on bishop before than bishop
c5 but i did remember
obviously i should have um
known much more about the position than
i did
but he also seemed to acknowledge him to
to
to stop at uh after queen e3 so queen e3
was the end of your preparation let's
put it that way yeah because it's just
the main line it goes the b5 c5 or maybe
i miss i could not b5 is absolutely the
main line no of course yeah so b6 uh
it's just a bad very bad move yeah i
assume you know so here i was like
thinking and thinking it was to to
of course i knew it was a mistake but to
punish it in these positions uh is so
difficult so
so how did you try what was your thought
process here of course i thought of um
h4 but
i thought that what i played was simply
the most direct
so okay my thought process is okay
usually okay let's say h4
it's saying uh okay it's saying now
h3 rookie
yeah so so
to understand this you have to like
understand that um
uh
this is let's say the best plan because
what i played
with bishop d3 i mean and and uh yes and
now again queen g3 is it's a mistake but
it's like there's so many uh
and and here i was forced after rookie
to play this uh rook he one you actually
spent a lot of time in this decision
yeah um
[Music]
it's not really the move it's what i was
going to play it's whether i was going
to play c5 or cb5 so perhaps i should
have played ricky rick h1 so he played
bishop h3 no no he played b5 yeah b5 and
then we went through this c5 yesterday
described it as a bowling ball going
down yeah yeah so but but yeah of course
i should have uh
this h4 work history idea i should have
seen yeah sorry to interrupt you real
quick there we have another result from
carolina has drawn his game against
linear dominguez there's certainly going
to be a disappointment for fabiano but
let's continue with this analysis you
were telling us about this position
yeah so
i i i knew i had a big advantage after
b6 but to capitalize was difficult but
okay obviously let's say i play cb5
instead of uh so c6b5 bishop b6 a4 c6
that queen h3 yeah uh takes take uh uh
take e6 yeah i saw all this take an e60
yeah so now uh de6
this should be it
takes yes yes king
okay there's a few options there's
there's even uh there's king a2 there's
king c2 there's okay let's say king a2
how do you evaluate this end game oh
just equal equal yeah perhaps but the
problem is that a lot of these end games
with the bishops uh these double pawns
are going there's going to be so many
fortresses right because
um i don't really have a breakthrough
so now i evaluated this is just going to
be a draw
so i thought you know why not
[Applause]
this position okay the fact that d5 is
the best move and d6
it's very counterintuitive yeah because
your
your eyes are just looking at this uh
this king right he made he played a5
which is a mistake yeah oh and now i'm
no i'm better yeah okay so i should have
played queen h4 first okay fine
but bishop g2 and now now i was just in
control yeah queen h4 yes and i played
ah queen g queen d4 is also very precise
okay very nice
rugby sound
taking a5 but oh wow i played so well
you can be surprised with yourself well
uh when you're going down on time it's
like the thing is that in these first
two games i know they're my opponents
are playing terribly you know i'm like
what are these guys doing i thought
they're supposed to be top players so
i'm trying to punish
and uh
no of course yeah this is all correct
yeah rook eb8 but he was just way too
optimistic well were you sure you're
gonna clinch this point
okay
the queen gamer was completely sure now
already
this way position
yeah this position i was quite confident
because i had foreseen this position and
foreseen that
the
you know to have the pawn on g6 um
is very nice in these end games because
you always have some triangulation
checks you know right so uh
and i thought like um
in any case i i should be faster
um with these two double pawns and uh
it's really nice to have these two pawns
because it's just you cover
this queen b5 king v7 i found the right
construction so he plays queen a1 and
maybe here what was i supposed to play
king b4 is correct yeah yeah but you
should note like i have like um 30
seconds here so uh perhaps it wasn't
that precise no you were you were fine
oh i was yeah yeah oh i don't see the
valiation changing that's a good thing
yes
so i played well
yes not bad not but not bad oh no it's
uh
i definitely should have found this h4
because h4 is my first instinct right
but
i think after that considering the time
situation i i kept my nerves well and i
didn't let uh him intimidate me another
victory there for the white piece is
that yandere pony actually does put the
finishing touches on alireza ferrugia
and comes back to the tournament has
this your first win against the 2750
plus how what does that do for your mood
it's okay
but that's not a surprise to me that i'm
beating these players so
perhaps uh
you know
when i've said i've improved quite a lot
lately so i've sort of become numb to
these these rapid changes for me in my
mind i'm already you know a top player
so
winning a game uh confirms that
but um
my confidence
of course can be strengthened by such a
win
but um
confidence comes from commitment and
hard work so
not just winning
well there you go hans niemann with an
important victory against shakira
medyarov good luck in the rest of the
term we certainly hope to see many more
victories from you thank you
thank you very much
hans
our congratulations
very entertaining game